brendan did you used to watch that show
90 day fiance oh yeah i still do i saw
an article the other day a girl who was
on that show makes a bunch of money
selling jars of her farts so that's like
which one i did i forgot what her name
was i'd never watched the show but it
was on yahoo
selling farts let me see that chin
that's incredible that's such a weird
yeah i'm always i'm always cute how do
people get there well
you can buy used undies uh in vending
machines
yeah okay with that that at least and by
the way there are plenty of videos of
hot girls wow she's made fifty thousand
dollars in one week
oh
which one the the one the writer normal
hair stephanie the one on the left yeah
yeah she was pretty much oh she's the
one with the mom that that yeah i
remember this bless you
thank you
so she just farts in the jar and this
her
she claims that she made 50 000 in a
week of a girl who sells her farts in a
jar so i like to get things a roll in
with some beans a protein muffin
sometimes even a yogurt
while i wait for those parts to develop
i like to read i'm very smart love to
read and wait for those farts to develop
i'm ready to go i go ahead and you know
do my work do my job i don't need to
show you that guys but i like to add a
little flower petals i feel like they
attach the scent and make it last longer
and when i'm finally finished with my
jar i like to leave a personalized note
i want to thank you so much the 97
people who have already purchased their
jar of farts 97 people
i feel like we should
do
that
you and i sell our farts
i think you guys can make pretty decent
i swear to god i'll [ __ ] sell my
farts that's just [ __ ] gross you
don't have to you don't have to do that
how about no one has to do for christmas
let's make it
a year a week she cleans 50 grand a week
it could have been just like one really
good week and then i don't know she's
consistently making that yeah
what do you think i can make what do you
think oh
seven dollars
it's such a hard pass
make seven dollars a month
you would sell one to some freaky dude
you just gotta find your niche there has
to be someone you want it doesn't have
to be that brian like you don't have the
roots of farts like you can have there's
something else that people want of you
yeah well i'm just gonna yeah i'm gonna
do colin calling where you can call me
and ask me questions
she's pretty hot man so that's the girl
she met on 90 day
uh yeah they're both on 90. uh no i
don't think she's with that girl they
didn't really get along they fought a
lot
oh they're they're not together
no one works out on that show
yeah she's very pretty yeah sexy yeah
she's sexy she's had some work done
well that's filters too right
does she fart online
um i don't know if she farts online i
just saw the article about her selling
her farts
maybe she does yeah how did it get to
that how did they come like yo i want
your farts maybe she got a weird dm
maybe she had a bunch of dms and she was
like man i guess i'll sell my farts it's
like me and the feet
everyone has their origin story but
that's feet that's not that's not a
[ __ ] real both weird foot fetishes
some people like to be jerked you like
feet
it's not i mean i don't mind like if you
had some hideous toes
like you had some raptor claws like
goddamn girl but socks
yeah i there was a guy i appreciate nice
feet you ever suck a toe no i a girl i
did a girl who was hot but she had her
feet and her hands were just they're
just too big for me they're too big oh
too big just she had a giant big toe
yeah and a big knuckle